I finished a book in the early part of
2007 for publication in october two
thousand seven on current and national
affairs because i think that the most
important overarching thing going on is
that the United States has to again
become the land of opportunity in the
land and the place that operates
according to principles so it's called
America the principled six opportunities
for becoming a can-do nation once again
and so those six opportunities seemed to
me to be the most important issues one
is how do we secure our future and
security isn't simply a matter of
watchdogs at airports it's a matter of
economic security that's how we keep
jobs in the United States for Americans
that's how we ensure that we have the
technology to make us safe and that
requires investments in innovation and
it requires open minds so the life
sciences are so important and yet they
have been so discredited by an
administration that has not cared about
science we're not doing enough to
educate people in the u.s. in science
and math which are so important to our
future most of the engineering and
science degrees being given in the
United States today advanced degrees
PhDs are going to foreign nationals or
people of foreign origins and as far as
I'm concerned they're welcome here but I
would also like to see our young people
get those degrees so that's if that's
the first challenge I'm very concerned
about the disappearing middle class and
the problems of balancing work and
family that women have so pursuing
happiness was something that's written
into our earliest origins life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness an awful
lot of people aren't happy because they
don't have health care because they have
to take two jobs they don't they're
worried about their children so that's
an important issue clearly the war in
Iraq is an important issue currently but
it's part of a larger problem of how do
we engage with the world
our form of engagement only
saber-rattling or are we making those
grassroots investments in the economic
development of other countries and the
development of their leaders so that we
have more allies and friends around the
world that's a major challenge we are
not liked in many parts of the world
well actually there's a gap between
liking Americans as a people and liking
the American government many more people
like Americans than like the American
government we have and speaking of
government we have a problem with
respect for government in fact in recent
years people have discredited government
because so many government officials
have done things that are ethically
challenged to put it in a positive way
but a lot of Washington was under
indictment for a while so if we don't
restore respect for government I'm sick
of politicians running against
government I'm running for this office
because I believe that we shouldn't have
these offices it's ridiculous so we need
respect so that good people run for
office in turn they appoint confident
people and they care about how well
government is run it's an it's a
traditional American principle to say
that government is best which governs
least but frankly it can't govern least
unless it governs better because it's
much more costly to have a disaster like
Hurricane Katrina than it would have
been to invest in the levees in New
Orleans in the first place and finally I
think we need a spirit of service the
partisan divides and the partisan
ugliness in America has plagued us if we
spend so much time arguing with each
other while fighting wars that we can't
possibly win and probably shouldn't have
been in in the first place then we will
never heal this nation we need things
that bring us together across partisan
divides as well as divides of race or
age or or urban versus rural and I think
community service and the generosity of
American philanthropy are things that
can unite
again so those are the themes that I've
been writing about those are the things
that I want on the agenda for the
presidential election in 2008 those are
the things in the news that bother me
the most but also inspire me to think
about solutions
you